two days ago Trump promised a major
announcement all caps many speculated
that he was going to announce his
running mate
perhaps he would announce a slate of big
endorsements
perhaps he would announce a coup d'etat
but instead
Trump announced that he would be selling
expensive computer cartoons of himself
hello everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
Washington with an important
announcement to make I'm doing my first
official Donald J Trump nft collection
right here and right now they're called
Trump digital trading cards these cards
feature some of the really incredible
artwork pertaining to my life and my
career it's been very exciting you can
collect your Trump digital cards just
like a baseball card or other
Collectibles here's one of the best
parts each card comes with an automatic
chance to win amazing prizes like dinner
with me I don't know if that's an
amazing prize but it's what we have or
golf with you and a group of your
friends at one of my beautiful golf
courses and they are beautiful I'm also
doing Zoom calls a one-on-one meeting
autographing memorabilia and so much
more we're doing a lot
the prize is dinner with me I don't know
if that's an amazing prize but it's what
we've got I love it I love it it's
obviously a troll it's obviously funny
it's Charming in fact self-effacing
humble even
but that's all it was it was just a big
joke
Trump has always been funny and he was
especially funny in 2016. but in 2016 he
was funny with a purpose he made jokes
about illegal aliens
to argue for closing the Border
they're rapists they're murderers some
are maybe good people okay but it was
too it's a joke but it's a joke that has
a lot of truth to it and it's a joke for
a political purpose he made jokes about
trade deals
for the purpose of defending the
American worker he made jokes about the
fake news
for the purpose of breaking the power of
the lying press yesterday Trump made a
joke about superheroes to
sell some expensive jpegs
we all want Trump to be funny but no one
wants Trump to be frivolous
he is entitled to raise as much money as
he can for whatever kind of pictures
that he wants obviously it's going to be
a very expensive campaign in 2024 but
this whole thing is going to fall flat
if no one knows what that campaign is
for I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday's from Scott who says
are you tired of getting kicked out of
restaurants who hate your guts just
because of your beliefs visit Jeremy's
Steakhouse instead
Jeremy boring hopefully someday I know
it's very frustrating that that
restaurant in Nashville canceled our
reservation
because it's going to cost daily wire so
much time and money now that Jeremy is
going to have to become Emeril Lagasse
it's off Jeremy's now going to have to
go on this whole multi-million dollar
detour to become Mario Batali but I'm
sure listen I'm sure the restaurant will
be great 100 jpegs are not going to win
the 2024 presidential race I know we're
two years out I know that there's not
very much that Donald Trump can do right
now he is not in political office
so his Rivals notably Ron DeSantis can
do lots of things
but
Donald Trump can't seem frivolous it's
good when he seems silly it's good when
he seems funny it's good when he seems
irreverent that actually helps
distinguish him from the rest of the
Republican candidates who just don't
have as much Razzle Dazzle celebrity As
Trump does Trump's one of the biggest
celebrities in the last 40 years
but it the jpegs are not going to win
the nomination okay I think right now of
Ron DeSantis within the same week
Donald Trump releases the 100 jpegs Ron
DeSantis and panels a grand jury to
investigate and prosecute the people who
pushed the covid lies and the covid
vaccines
as a republican voter I care much more
about the latter than I do about the
former I I don't know what Donald Trump
can do right now but he's got to seem a
little more focused
okay when I think about the 2016 race it
really wasn't all about him
he would put his name on things he would
he he would put his name on things like
he's put his name on things for 40 years
now big gold letters on top of buildings
but it seemed like that campaign was
about us that was that was his motto
remember Hillary Clinton had I'm with
her Trump said my motto is I'm with you
right he switched the subject of the
mutter and you really felt like this guy
is is doing this for us
he doesn't need to he's going to lose
money he's going to get a lot of agita
it's going to make his life worse in
many ways
but he's doing it for us
here I don't really see that what is
what is motivating the campaign is it
fixing trade is it fixing immigration
or is it telling jokes
I like jokes I like owning the lips but
I like doing it with a purpose
Trump used to have that energy of we're
going to panel the grand jury and we're
going to lock you up Dr fauci that
that's the subtext of impaneling the
grand jury the subtext is what Trump
said to Hillary in 2016 Hillary says I
wouldn't want to live in a country where
Donald Trump is President he says yeah
because you'd be in jail
boom owned love it yeah that'd be great
right now DeSantis is taking that energy
Trump trump is not speaking of wielding
power absolutely great news
Elon Musk is going on a Banning spree on
Twitter and he is Banning the libs this
all started because there was an account
called Elon Jett that was tracking in
real time Elon musk's private airplane
and this led to some very bad things one
Elon Musk is already getting lots of
threats against him but then Elon Musk
also just had an attack that I guess was
supposed to be against him it ended up
being against his little kid
his son was in a car
and some black clad antifa looking guy
pulls up to the car starts attacking the
car
the car didn't have Elon Musk in it
the car had his kid and so Elon is
fit to be tied at the moment and he has
gone on a Banning spree specifically
against people who have doxed him or
Amplified voices that have doxed him so
he's gone on a Banning spree
he banned the left-wing propagandist and
former Vox journalist Aaron rupar he
banned CNN reporter Donnie O'Sullivan he
banned New York Times Reporter Ryan Mack
he banned wapa reporter Drew Harwell he
banned intercept journalist Micah Lee I
don't really know anything about Michael
Lee he and he banned Keith olberman oh
my gosh it's just too delicious I just
love it I I was on Tim cast last night
and as this news broke we're all sitting
around there
and Luke on the show
huge libertarian me I'm not so
libertarian and so a lot of people raise
these concerns well what about free
speech
I don't mean to make fun of them but I
like the guys at the gymcast show a lot
they're friends of mine but
a lot of people out there in the media
as well and especially the left-wing
journalists I said what about free
speech what about the Free Speech
absolutism
I think I'm not a free speech absolutist
I think Elon Musk was 100
justified in Banning people who are
doxing him and threatening his family
100 Justified I would like to thank Elon
Musk
for vindicating and enacting
the view of free speech that I advocate
in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds number one National bestseller
right now right in time for Christmas do
I okay maybe the Bell is a little
delayed when I'm on the road I'm not so
sure but in any case thank you Elon the
book will still arrive in time for
Christmas depending on where you order
it from right now and you're seeing it
play out in real time
no one seriously believes that the first
amendment protects the right of leftist
political activists on the internet to
endanger the lives of Elon musk's
children okay no way
and I have to tell you even beyond the
principle of the whole thing
and in principle
Keith olberman has no right to a Twitter
account
but even beyond the principle
I do get a little bit of shot in freuda
when I look at these liberal journalists
dealing with something that
conservatives have been dealing with for
years
Keith Olbermann is at least as extreme
on the left-wing side as Alex Jones is
on the right wing side Keith olberman is
in fact much more extreme
much less reasonable
as a leftist then Ela then then Alex
Jones would be as a conservative
absolutely great stuff Tim made a really
really good point on the show last night
which is that he said
the letter of the law is important
but it requires judges to interpret it
you could go even further the letter of
the law is important but I I frequently
reference Adrian vermeul the
conservative Harvard law professor he
draws a distinction between two senses
of the law Lex and use
going speaking Latin by the way I'm not
just mispronouncing English words Lex
meaning the law as written in a statute
or in a constitution and use meaning the
background legal principles the context
in which that written law would exist
the letter killeth the spirit giveth
life okay and when we look at Twitter
right now yes there are some rules that
can be written down on paper here are
the new Twitter guidelines but it's
always going to require people to put
that into effect and I'll tell you I
trust Elon Musk a sort of Center
left-wing guy maybe now center right I
trust him to put it into effect much
more than I trust Vijaya Gadi and all of
the other lunatics who used to run
Twitter okay and there's nothing
unprincipled about saying that this is a
human society we live in a political
Community people are always going to
matter so yes we need the right rules
written down on the sheets of paper but
we also need wise prudent just people to
enact the rules that we have written
down
we need to be able to speak with one
another in a self-government when you
want to talk to your friends and
neighbors you've got to check out pure
talk right now go to puretalk.com use
promo code Knowles are you tired of
overpaying for your wireless network get
talk text and blazing fast data for just
thirty dollars a month Pure Talk gives
you the same network the same towers and
the same coverage as the other guys at
half the price merry Christmas everybody
pure talks us-based customer service
team makes the switch incredibly easy
and you can feel good knowing that you
are supporting a veteran-owned business
here's the best part when you go to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles you will
save an additional 50 off your first
month there is no reason to pay Verizon
ATT or T-Mobile over 80 a month for
wireless service when you can get the
same service on the same network at Pure
Talk for half
price go to puretalk.com enter code null
scanner wlas to save 50 off your first
month that is puretalk.com promo code
Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s for 50 off your first
month Pure Talk simply
smarter
Wireless
speaking of social media bands more
great news coming out of Capitol Hill
the GOP Congress is moving to ban Tick
Tock in the U.S and you know you know
that congressman
cannot resist a good acronym
initialisms and acronyms are absolute
catnip to members of the Congress and so
they have proposed
the
averting the national threat of an
Internet surveillance oppressive
censorship and influence and algorithmic
learning by the Chinese Communist Party
Act
also known as the anti-social CCP Act
boo that's so stupid but but the bill is
very good the title perhaps a little
silly the bill very very good
uh this is being proposed in the Senate
this is being proposed in the House of
Representatives Marco Rubio is helping
to lead the bipartisan charge in the
Senate uh this is a really important
law
the extreme libertarian Position will be
well we can't we don't want the
government interfering in the market and
if people want to download their tick
tocks and jiggle on camera and just
waste their time Doom scrolling for
hours a day that's their right
and now we have the right within the
political community
to set boundaries within the marketplace
and when it comes to tick tock
we have I think an obligation to
suppress Tick Tock in our country
because there is a national security
risk from tick tock tick tock is a way
for the Chinese Communist party to get
data from us and that's a really really
bad thing and Tick Tock is a way for the
Chinese Communist party to censor some
of the discourse within the United
States to help control the Public Square
which in a self-government means the
Chinese Communist Party would have a
fair amount of control over our
political order but furthermore
Tick Tock is just bad it is just digital
crack okay when you look at the amount
of time per day that Tick Tock users are
on the app versus say Twitter users it
is not even close there's one study
showed the average or median Twitter
user is on the app for two to six
minutes per day the average or medium
Tick Tock User it's it's upwards of an
hour okay it's a huge waste of time it's
a total psyop
and we should wield the power of the
state by which I mean the political
Community to put a stop to that people
are not really benefiting from Tick Tock
and we can know that and we can perceive
that and everybody deep down knows that
it's true and we should put a stop to it
because it's endangering National
Security it's also endangering our
psychology and our lives and our
productivity and our national soul
speaking of dangers coming from China
the house intelligence committee GOP has
just come out with a report that you're
going to be shocked to hear this if
you're driving pull over
if you're standing up have a seat
turns out
that covid
maybe didn't just start in nature
it maybe just wasn't a total accident
because of a bad batch of bat soup at
the wuhot wet Market
you're going to be shocked to find out
that
covet
actually
may have come from
the Wuhan laboratory and that kovid
actually may have been part of a Chinese
bio weapons program you're gonna be
shocked to find out that the wild-eyed
crazy tinfoil hat conspiracy theorists
were actually very likely right about
everything regarding covid from the very
beginning here's what the report says
contrary to the implication of the
intelligence community's Declassified
report based on our investigation
involving a variety of public and
non-public information we conclude that
there are indications that sarsko V2 may
have been tied to China's biological
weapons research program and spilled
over to the human population during a
lab-related incident the Wuhan Institute
of virology the IC the intelligence
Community failed to adequately address
this information in its classified
updated assessment
when we attempted to raise the issues
with the IC it failed to respond
there you have it now why might the IC
and other branches of the administrative
agencies in the Deep State why might
they not be so interested in admitting
that SARS cov2 covid-19 the wuflu
whatever you want to call it may very
likely have been part of a Chinese
bioweapons program
well
one because the United States obviously
is conducting similar research this
became a big issue when certain bio Labs
were uncovered in Eastern Europe as part
of the Ukraine war but two because the
U.S funded the laboratory
because the U.S was funding this kind of
research on back coronaviruses and had
subset grants to the Wuhan Institute of
virology through Peter dashiak and
through Eco Health Alliance
so you've got
a combination here of culpability and
incompetence in the federal government
and so they don't want to admit that
they're doing that so they're they're
trying to cover it up they've been
trying to cover it up for two and a half
years I'm really pleased to see
that the House GOP is coming in and
they're at least willing to talk about
these things
we need to go further though
we need to be Vindicated we have been
gaslit for so so long we need some
we need some Vindication okay I if if
all the House GOP does is obstruct
Biden's worst plans and uncover this
kind of stuff that will have been a
great service
speaking of things that hate you things
that hate I'm sorry things that can hurt
you
speaking of things that can hurt you Jay
Leno has had his face set on fire we
covered this a couple of weeks ago when
it first happened Jay Leno loves working
on cars and he had oil and gas sputter
out of a car and then there was a light
that was already lit and it lit his
whole face on fire he goes to the
hospital and this guy
just jokes about it so he's out of
surgery they seem to have fixed his face
up fairly well
Leno says quote eight days later I had a
brand new face and it's better than what
was there before
I'm sorry I'll try that again hey later
I got a brand new faith and it's better
than what we did before
you know and he just says it as a joke
as a total throwaway that's a very funny
line he says when you look at me you
don't really worry about what you look
like look if I'm George Clooney it's
going to be a huge problem they said it
would be all right my attitude is I
trust people who are the best to do what
they have to do
he then said the most expensive part of
the whole operation was the gasoline
we're in California it's seven bucks a
gallon so he just keeps telling jokes I
think he's already performing again
there were reports that after a couple
days in the hospital Leonard was going
around telling jokes to kids who were in
the hospital it's just just up on his
feet very buoyant and a lot of people
are looking at this and they're saying
wow this is great
good for Jay Leno I wish I had that
attitude for me I stubbed my toe it
ruins my whole day for me someone cuts
me off in traffic I'm still whining
about it Jay Leno gets his face burnt
off and he's telling jokes about it days
later
wow what a guy I wish I could be like
that
my question is
what's the alternative to being like
that
yes it's great clearly Jay Leno has
cultivated
certain virtues that have allowed him to
remain buoyant but my question is for
those of us who have not done that yet
what's the alternative
we're just going to whine and be
miserable all the time a Jay Leno is not
only doing something that's virtuous
here he's doing something that's wise
and smart and in his self-interest
he's not going to be to be benefiting by
whining and crying all the time about
what's happened whether it's spilled
milk or burning his face off he's just
going to move on with his life now
speaking of late night hosts
a late night has really gone downhill
since Jay Leno left
Stephen Colbert has a lot to say if
about the potential 2024 presidential
race because right now Donald Trump not
doing very very well right now Ron
DeSantis doing much better
but Stephen Colbert
he's already looking ahead to what
happens if DeSantis takes over Trump new
Wall Street Journal poll says that in a
hypothetical GOP Primary matchup
DeSantis beats the former president 52
to 38 percent
yay
also maybe boo it's hard to know who to
root for here it's like a poll between
gonorrhea and a slightly more racist
gonorrhea
this is
apologies to gonorrhea
gosh Donald Trump Donald Trump is Hitler
Donald Trump is the worst person to ever
hold the presidency he it's not just
that we hate all the Republicans and
conservatives Donald Trump is uniquely a
threat he's a fascist he's a Nazi we
have to stop Donald Trump
but Rhonda santhis is just as bad and I
told you this you know I hate to say I
Told You So I said this all the way back
in 2016.
they're all pretending that Trump is the
unique case
by the time Trump leaves office that
it's going to be the good old days oh
Donald Trump was bad but he wasn't as
bad as
insert the name of the next Republican
just like they did to George W Bush when
George Bush was president he was Hitler
now he's all the good old days George W
bush just the same thing with George H.W
bush they did the same thing to Ronald
Reagan they called him a white
supremacist and a Nazi and a skinhead
and all the rest of it I guess he
couldn't be a skinhead because he had
such a beautiful head of hair and so
right now actually the only silver
lining for Donald Trump in what's been
generally a pretty bad political news
cycle for him vis-a-vis the Republican
primary and Ron DeSantis is they haven't
really opened fire on DeSantis yet
so DeSantis is doing very very well in
the polls but the moment that they start
to turn their Firepower on Ron DeSantis
you were going to see those numbers come
down I'm not saying it's going to be
fair it's really never fair when the
media do that that is the game that they
play and so we've got to stay alert when
you want to stay alert you got to check
out Black Rifle coffee right now go to
blackrightfulcoffee.com use promo code
Knowles Black Rifle coffee company is
helping you knock out your Christmas
shopping with a ton of great new
products this year designed for folks
who love country and coffee you can shop
Brewing gear thermoses mugs and apparel
for 10 off with promo code Knolls Black
Rifle sources the most exotic roasts
from around the globe all coffee is
roasted here in the U.S by veteran-led
teams of coffee experts every purchase
you make with Black Rifle helps support
veteran and first responder causes daily
wire plus kitchens are stocked with
Black Rifle coffee and yours can be two
go to Black riflecoffee.com use promo
code Knowles Canada w-l-e-s for 10 off
coffee Coffee Gear apparel or when you
sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription that is black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles kwles
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee
head on over there right now they are
supporting veterans and America's coffee
speaking of rolling with the punches
a house Republican representative Carlos
Jimenez is urging Elon Musk to move
Twitter to Florida
not to move the Twitter digital platform
he's doing lots of moves there but to
move the physical headquarters to
Florida I think this would be a great
great move what Ximena says is quote
I'm writing to you as the former mayor
of Miami-Dade County who now has the
distinct honor of representing my
community in Congress we want to
encourage you to explore our free state
of Florida and make the move to relocate
Twitter to Miami-Dade County
foreign
this would solve a lot of musk's
problems
if he moved the headquarters from San
Francisco to Miami or something that
would solve a lot of musk problems you
remember right now musk is being
investigated because he he brought some
mattresses to the office for overworked
employees who want to take a quick nap
while he's being investigated for that
the government in San Francisco in
California obviously very very hostile
to musk they're going to continue to
launch investigations they're going to
pass laws to punish him and so what he
should do is move to Florida
it is a lesson that I've been trying to
drive home for a while but now we're
seeing it play out in real time
politics is not just your friends online
politics is not just about your Affinity
groups and uh some some Meetup chat or
something like that politics is about a
political Community man is a in in some
degree a physical being and so the
political Community is also where we
live if Elon musk's moves from
California to Florida
you will have a much easier time
conducting business just like the daily
wire has had a much easier time
conducting business when we move from LA
to Tennessee just like all sorts of
businesses have had a much easier time
since they moved from Florida to from
California to Florida from California to
Texas from California to Tennessee Elon
now is the time to do it it's going to
be a lot easier to move because you
fired or allowed to quit huge numbers of
the staff you're selling off a lot of
the merch Elon is probably several steps
ahead of us in planning this out already
but let's do it it would also seriously
help the culture War because we have to
show these people that there are
consequences to their terrible policies
and their terrible government take their
money away take their power centers away
I don't like the idea that three or four
entities control the Public Square
especially because they're semi-private
entities but I would feel a hell of a
lot better if not all of those entities
were based in Silicon Valley surrounded
by crazy Libs I would feel a lot better
if at least one of those entities
even if it's the smallest one
we're based in a conservative state
speaking of the GOP
there's a big explosive report
this report is out from Red State
says that
the RNC has been spending tons of money
and it's largely a political attack on
Ron and McDaniel who is the current
chairman of the Republican National
Committee I assume this is part of the
campaign right now there's a power
struggle who's going to be the next GOP
chairman is Ronald McDaniel going to
continue to serve is harmony Dylan who's
a friend of ours a California Republican
lawyer is she going to become the new
head of it there was a rumor that
Mercedes schlapp who's a former Trump
official who is married to Matlab have
the American conservative Union that she
might run
what is regardless of who's behind it
it's obviously an attack on Ronald
McDaniel and I have to say there are
many reasons to attack the RNC and the
House GOP leadership and the Senate GOP
leadership this one seems a little bit
weak to me if you look at the money that
was spent on private jets the money that
was spent on limousines luxury Retreats
Broadway shows you know it all sounds
really bad in the headline it's not a
ton of money
the money that was spent on private jets
half a million dollars
that's what 10 flights
10 to 15 flights that's really not a ton
of money over this period of time over a
year
for a major American political party to
spend on chartered flights because
sometimes to get to fundraisers to get
to big events to get there on time to
places where they don't have commercial
flights I don't know that just doesn't
seem crazy to me
the floral arrangements food and
beverage alcohol again it sounds really
bad they spent 36 500 on alcohol well
yeah they're throwing events they're
raising money I this this seems a little
bit weak to me
I mean all All is fair and Love and War
and politics but the reasons to go after
the RNC are the failure of the RNC to
support good candidates to win elections
to counter the Democrats strategies in
terms of ballot harvesting in terms of
changing the laws in certain states to
to benefit one party over the other
that's that's why one would go after
them but spending a little bit of money
on booze at fundraisers I don't know
that that doesn't do a whole lot for me
you know what you know what I think
would be significant
what you're seeing in Georgia right now
in Georgia the secretary of state is
moving to end runoff elections which I
think is great Brad raffensberger has
just called on the state legislature to
eliminate runoff elections after last
week because we we saw the Herschel
Walker and Rafael Warnock campaign
it was a really close call on Election
night so it goes on for another few
weeks then it goes into December and
okay Warnock barely edges it out we need
to get rid of this stuff okay the the
runoffs generally only serve
the
Democrats sometimes Republicans can win
I'm not saying that's always right
against the Democrats but I just think
what what conservatives and Republicans
should be aiming at
is to
reduce the size of the election
we need to get rid of the mail-in
ballots we need to get rid of election
season we need to get rid of the runoffs
we need to get rid of ranked Choice
voting we need to get we just need to
bring it it's much easier to control for
shenanigans when the election takes
place on Election Day and people have to
show up
so anyway
that we can reduce the size of the
election that is what we have to do
there's even more great political news
by the way that's coming out of Loudoun
County before before we take a break and
go over to the member block I do have to
mention this in Loudoun County the
superintendent there
has just been indicted uh this guy
superintendent Scott Ziegler was the one
who permitted
ridiculous bathroom policies that
encouraged a rape to take place a boy in
the girls bathroom at Loudoun County all
sorts of gender bending craziness but
that wasn't even the worst part the rape
was the worst part but then the worst
part from the standpoint of policy was
that the superintendent
just moved the kid to another school he
knew about it he didn't really follow up
on it he just tried to brush the problem
under the rug and then what happened
the kid raped someone again
it was all this big cover-up because it
was so Politically Incorrect to say the
boy shouldn't go into the girl's
bathroom and the gender bending students
obviously have some psychological
problems
well now that guy's being indicted love
that
this guy lied this guy there's there's
more to say on this story but this is a
great use of political power I mean I
just keep coming back to this in all of
these fronts when we're talking about
social media when we're talking about
local school boards when we're talking
about the national government when we're
talking about what corporations we're
talking about all of it we need to wield
our power because if we don't if we if
all we do is issue strong statements or
crack jokes
then the libs are going to get away with
it and they're going to keep keep on
with their terrible policies that are
destroying the country okay now
we are heading on to my absolute
favorite time of the week that is when I
get to hear from you in the voicemail
bag if you have not submitted a
voicemail bag this week make sure you
get it in for next week you head on over
the Michael Knoll show page you click on
boob submit a question send in your
voice mail bag keep it under a minute so
I don't I don't need your whole life
story okay we got to be able to play it
on air but uh make sure you head on over
and do that I had a huge year in 2022
guys
so did daily wire plus we release
choosing death the legacy of row I put
out Dr fauci's Unmasked A great
documentary putting the man himself
under a microscope if I do say so myself
and of course we put out what is a woman
Terror on the Prairie greatest lie ever
sold Dr Jordan B Peterson joined our
fold
as great as that year was we have so
much in store for this coming year you
will see it all if you are a member if
you're already a member thank you if
you're not yet a member now is the time
to join this Christmas season you can
get 30 off new daily wire plus annual
memberships and gift memberships when
you use code holiday at checkout what
that means is there's only a short time
left to take advantage of our final sale
of 2022 go to dailywire.com Knowles use
code holiday at checkout to get 30 off
new daily wire plus memberships that is
dailywire.com Knowles today
the voicemail bag is sponsored by pure
talk at puretalk.com select a plan enter
code nulls to get 50 off your first
month take it away
Hey There Michael so my situation is I
am a young adult
I don't really do much of anything I'm
not interested in partying drinking
going to bars none of that
I spend most of my time at church where
everyone's either a lot younger or a lot
older than I am
I recently moved to a new area for work
and I don't know how I'm ever going up
on demand
like I feel like I'm going to be alone
forever because
most young adults that I know go to bars
on the weekends
or go out and do things and be social
I have maybe one friend who I go out
with
a few times a month Maybe
and that's hiking so I mean I'm not the
most social person I'm not an interested
in compromising my beliefs
but I don't know how to meet someone
with the same interest as me if that
makes sense I would love your advice
thank you so much
first thing to do
take some pressure off yourself okay
you're you're clearly feeling from this
pressure I've got to go out I've got to
meet a man this is it this is one of my
three times a month I go out it's got to
happen if it doesn't happen now I'm
gonna die alone
it's okay
it's it's all right relax
if you go out with that kind of attitude
you're not going to have a good very
good time you're probably not going to
meet anybody and you're going to be very
very disappointed so it's okay
what you need to do is you you say you
don't really like going to bars and
restaurants
you do like going to church but the
people at your church are very very old
are very very young
so I would recommend maybe looking for
another church or if you really love
your church just different groups
affiliated with churches where you might
find young people
that is your interest so you can find
people who share that interest there and
it's a very good interest to have God is
a very good interest to have I would
recommend I'm not sure if you're a
Catholic but if you are Catholic I would
recommend you check out a traditional
Latin Mass I actually would recommend it
even if you're not Catholic but uh
that's not only because I find it to be
the most beautiful liturgy ever but also
because for your needs right now
that's where all the young people are
the Young
uh
family-oriented people who are really
interested in community are attending
the Latin Mass I know that seems sort of
counter-intuitive but it's because
young people unlike the boomers are more
interested I think in Orthodoxy in rigor
in truth not just the soft soap
hippy-dippy Age of Aquarius stuff but
they they want all the sorts of things
that you are describing that you want
and so uh that that would be one venue I
assume no matter what your denomination
is that there is some version of it that
attracts younger people I hope I'm
actually not totally confident of that
but one would certainly hope so and then
there are organizations related to the
church volunteer charitable
organizations that might do that uh
furthermore
you can Avail yourself of the dating
apps I'm not saying it's the best
solution I'm not saying that I would be
eager to do it if I were single but that
is where people are these days and you
don't just have to go on some completely
degenerate dating app you don't just
need to you know swipe right all the
time on some hookup app there are apps
out there where you can meet people who
are interested in longer term sorts of
things and and I don't think there's
anything wrong with engaging in the
culture
within the parameters that the culture
allows okay and you can don't abuse it
so that you're just hooking up all the
time but I know people who have gotten
great marriages out of dating apps okay
so that that's what I would do take the
pressure off of yourself but just calmly
steadily
pursue the the
people and the interests that you want
where they are and sometimes that'll
mean by the way if you don't want to go
out to a bar or restaurant oh it's a
Friday night I'm kind of tired I just
don't well maybe you should maybe you
should push yourself with your friends
that you go out with say you know we
actually should be social tonight and go
out and chat with some people but there
are other ways too you don't you don't
need to just meet your husband your
future husband at a bar okay next
question
hello Michael happy Friday to you I pray
you and your family are well and I thank
you for putting on your show I enjoy it
tremendously I am curious to get your
brief thoughts on the age-old question
of passion versus provision When
selecting one's line of work or career
path the background to this question is
that at one time I was a hopeful
academic I had started a doctoral degree
and was excelling in European history
and my goal was to be a professor and
that was my passion really still is to
this day but through one thing or
another in God's Providence I left
academics uh did not complete my
doctoral degree and got into business
ownership instead and I now run a small
business that does very well and I
mainly left because I'm an Evangelical
Christian and I have a wife and five
children and I felt that I could better
provide for and afford more
opportunities for my family and my
church through business ownership than I
could through academics however I still
oftentimes struggle with a deep sense of
loss or regret thinking about out the
fact that I did leave what I love to do
something that I love less but is better
for others around me so briefly if you
could give your thoughts on that concept
and how we should weight passion versus
provision When selecting lines of work I
would appreciate it thank you
good example I will use is my friend
Spencer Clavin Spencer Clavin a genius
academic I have known him since his
freshman year in college my sophomore
year in college and we have been friends
ever since uh then Spencer went on got
his PhD at Oxford in Classics I think in
ancient Greek music criticism you know
this this guy is as academic and
scholarly as it gets he doesn't teach at
a college right now he could have but
that would have made other aspects of
his life more difficult he didn't want
to have to move to palucoville he didn't
want to get on that really awful kind of
track where you don't make any money and
you don't have a ton of control over
your life and there's all the sorts of
problems that you're you're describing
and then on top of that you say you have
to provide for your family and so that's
that's not going to cut it so what does
Spencer do
he starts a podcast called young
Heretics a fabulous podcast one of the
few that I listen to uh Spencer
writes books Spencer develops an an
audience by writing on his blog and so
he feeds not only the
the financial needs of his life but also
the intellectual needs I mean I I feel
you I I have plenty of academic and
scholarly interests I am I'm not an
academic I do not work in Academia at
all but I do try to make time in my day
to read and to read certain sort of
esoteric or more academic things and
then I try to incorporate that into my
daily life
I host a talk show I go around to
college campuses but I I tailor those
circumstances within my life to the the
interests that I have where if I pursued
those interests
100 of the time I would not have a great
existence I think you can do that too I
suspect I know you're very busy the
man's a business that demands
of your family are very busy but you can
work these things in together we've come
to this crazy conclusion in modernity
that we have to be increasingly
specialized and siled and
compartmentalized in our interests you
really don't have to be I don't think
you can work all of these things you can
work in your faith you can work in your
academic interest you can work in your
family you can work all of this into so
much more of your life and that will
give you by the way not only the
satisfaction of pursuing your interests
it will give you a much more integrated
life so that you won't feel so
schizophrenic all the time so that you
won't feel like you're one person at the
office and one person at home and one
person reading your book but you're
you're the same person moving and
weaving all of these different facets of
your character in throughout the day
next question
hey Michael being a Christian woman I
want to take care of my husband and
serve him to the best of my ability and
I know men are different in some ways
but I just wanted to know what you think
is the best ways that a wife can serve
her husband thanks Michael
wow
I
whatever you're doing I'm sure you're
doing it just great that very question I
I'm looking at Mr Davies over here in
the corner you know I can you can't see
he's off camera
wow
Michael just tell me how can a wife
serve her husband
just by asking that question just by
thinking of your marriage in those terms
you're doing it okay
how can a wife serve her husband and a
husband should probably ask how can I
love my wife
how can I love my wife it's not so easy
to serve your husband and really to
serve your whole family all the time so
much of the work that wives and mothers
do is is not glamorous
and people do not always express their
gratitude for it and it's this constant
steady work of these small acts of love
that are just so consistent that they
create a whole universe they create the
whole context in which you live they
create your home
and and often men
don't think how can I love my wife how
can I always be loving my wife even when
my wife is nagging me about that thing
that I don't want to do or even when my
wife does something that I don't
appreciate or don't how and if you if
you I think if you just ask yourself
those questions regularly
you're on the track to a good marriage
next question
hi Michael Katie here you may also know
me as satosha Kate orgater on Twitter or
just cater gator in the member block I'm
asking about someone who called in today
to talk about the greater Idaho movement
I'm looking at the map here and I'm
disappointed that it fails to cover more
of my state Nevada specifically places
like Elko which has legalized licensed
brothels also we have gambling and all
sorts of sinning so Prince prison
Michael self-proclaimed sex symbol
chased and based what will you as a
leader do to ensure that more of my
state gets annexed also what will you do
with the brothels once prostitution
becomes illegal as it should will you
turn them into cigar lounges or will you
do what powerful people in Vegas do
which is blow them up to build something
better looking forward to your answer
thank you
well I I love your question and I love
your mode of addressing me as well I
appreciate that recognizing that I am in
fact an international sex symbol uh
chasten based swarthy as can be uh so on
that point I'll answer the second part
first what would I do with the brothel
so we say okay we gotta shut down the
brothels this is not good for anybody
really there there is a Christian
argument for not shutting down brothels
this was the argument made by Augustine
and reiterated by Saint Thomas Aquinas
which is that
if you don't have if you move to Outlaw
prostitution and brothels that already
exist then Society will just go crazy
with lust and you'll have increases in
violence and rape uh so there actually
is a an argument for
not totally outlawing these things
although obviously what's going on in
Las Vegas is just terrible and at the
very least I think everyone agrees one
should curtail those kinds of vices if
not outlaw them all together but then
assuming we do outlaw
would I renovate them and turn them into
cigar lounges or would I knock them down
and build something new it would have to
be the latter and it would have to be
the latter because if you allow some
Vestige of these things to persist
there will be a Temptation toward them
I think of a great book by Dom Lorenzo
scoopely called the spiritual combat and
this is a 500 year old book very
important to to understanding the
spiritual combat that we're always in
and uh scoopely writes that for so many
sins and vices
we can look at them we can confront them
head on but when we're talking about
lusts when we're talking about sexual
Temptations you really do just have to
flee okay you've just got to run away
you will not be able to face them head
on and I suspect that's because we are
we're largely sexual beings you know
that that is a real core part of who we
are the drive for sex is a stronger
drive and the Temptation toward lust is
is a stronger Temptation than say my
Temptation toward gluttony which I have
that too okay I got all of them in
Spades but but the the sexual drive is
stronger and so I would knock that down
and I would I would then of course build
the Cigar Lounge on the spot where they
were out of different materials with a
different sort of design
uh how will we make the greater Idaho
movement how will we allow it to take
over more of your state well I think it
needs to go National okay I think that
we can't be so uh short-sighted to say
well we'll just open up the Greater
Idaho movement and have Idaho take over
just a few more little areas around it
no it's got to go National baby we need
the whole country to be Idaho it's like
that Meme of the astronauts one of whom
is holding a gun at someone said the guy
says it's all Ohio and the the astronaut
holding the nonsense it always was it's
got It's all got to be Idaho okay and
and that way we will live in a good
flourishing normal country and get rid
of Gamora by the Sea over there on the
west coast in California and all the
madness in New York as well the rest of
the show continues now I have got a
great
written mailbag question from a retired
Jewish Christmas tree salesman I'm very
excited to answer I just see that name
right up there at the top so you'll have
to head over to the members block to
hear that question and answer it's also
fake headline Friday so fake headline
Friday is of course where Mr Davies
gives me five headlines and I need your
help to understand which one is the fake
headline we will be doing that right now
please come over and help me if you're
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]